A pet peeve or pet hate is a minor annoyance that can extremely frustrate someone.
Typically everyone has several pet peeves that aggravate him more than the average person.
Another person may not react as negatively or at all to the same circumstance.
Often pet peeves will seem illogical to others.
Someone who hates others for being late is often late himself.
Some peeves are so universal that they are not really peeves but just bad behavior.
For example,...
...everyone dislikes the behavior of blowing one's nose at the dinner table.
Pet peeves are typically of common occurrences and a person may encounter his pet peeve very often.
An example of this would be someone not using his turn signal while driving;...
...while some drivers feel frustrated when another driver does not use his turn signal,...
...other drivers do not care very much.
Many pet peeves associated with driving can result in road rage,...
...where the person who feels peeved seeks some sort of retribution.
The Internet offers many ways to fight the things that annoy us.
For example, to coexist with loud cell phone talkers,...
...the Web offers handheld jammers that, although illegal in the United States,...
...can block all cell phone signals within a 15 - meter radius.
Another inventor has developed and sold about 30,000 of his keychain - size zappers called...
...TV-B-Gone through the Internet,...
...which can be used discreetly to switch off televisions in public places.